what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video before I get
started I want to give a shout out to my
friend Piz for pointing something out to
me in the opening credits of season
seven after I saw this I started to do
some research to see if there's a chance
that the knight King on his army will
actually go around the wall instead of
knocking it down once I looked into this
a little bit further I think there is a
very good chance this is going to happen
so let's take a look at the evidence and
when the video ends let me know what you
think now let's get started first let's
start with the hounds vision in episode
1 forests of Muir had to hound come over
to the fire and look into the flames and
when he did this he saw some things that
were pretty alarming and actually laid
the groundwork for what will happen in
the upcoming episodes the hound said he
saw ice a wall of ice it's where the
wall meets the sea and there is a castle
there in a mountain that looks like an
arrowhead in the dead or marching past
thousands of them now think about what
he actually said he said he can see the
wall right where it meets the sea and
there is a castle there he is actually
looking at eastwatch-by-the-sea and he
can see the dead marching past it not
over it not for it but he sees them
marching past it as if they are going
around it but this isn't the only
interesting thing about this scene there
was actually a line of dialogue that
they had removed from this episode and I
think they had it taken out because it
would have been too obvious as to what
was going to happen next the removed
line of dialogue was during the hounds
vision the Hound was also supposed to
say the waves are frozen which means the
sea has completely frozen over and
that's why the dead are able to march
right past the castle where the wall of
ice meets the sea now let's take a look
at the opening credits from episode one
in Episode two when it shows the wall in
the credits look at the sea to the right
side of the wall right where
eastwatch-by-the-sea is it has
completely frozen over this is going to
allow the night king and his army to go
right around the wall instead of
knocking it down now look at the opening
credits from season 6 episode 9 this was
just a few episodes ago and the sea is
still completely blue but now it's
frozen over now that winter is here and
when the night king brings the store
it's going to be even colder but there
are a few other things I want to point
out though remember in episode 1 right
after the credits end we go right into a
vision that bran Stark is having as he
is seeing the dead marching with the
storm as he is seeing the army of the
Dead with the three giants we'll take a
look at the ground right here right
before we see the army of the Dead
marching with the storm to me that looks
like they're walking over frozen water
the ground then the forefront right here
looks very blue and it's not flat ground
either it looks to be like choppy water
has frozen over I think bran was looking
into the future right here
and he was watching the army of the Dead
March as they were about to go out onto
the frozen sea when I first saw this I
thought it was just some field they were
marching on but after I looked at it for
a while I think it could be the water
frozen right in place but I have a few
other clues from the books that actually
point toward the Dead coming into the
water and out of the water there was a
character in the books called patch face
and he is a really creepy character that
is always saying these really weird
things that seem to be very prophetic in
a Dance with Dragons patch faces at the
wall as Jon Snow and some other
characters are talking about taking an
expedition to hardhome to save the
wildlings there is another character
there called mal Gorn and he asked Jon
Snow who's going to lead this ranging to
hardhome and this is when patch face
says I will lead it we will march into
the sea and out again under the waves we
will ride sea horses and mermaids will
blow sea shells to announce her coming
what he says here is very interesting
patch face is another character in the
books that has died and come back to
life he is technically another form of a
wight a reanimated character so think
about what he says that Jon Snow while
they're at the wall he says we will
march into the sea in out again I think
he means the Dead will march into the
sea and out again he says under the ways
we will ride sea horses this could just
mean horses will be on the sea dead
horses from the knight king's army then
he says mermaids will blow sea shells to
announce our coming that can mean men of
the Nights Watch will blow the horn
three times which means the White
Walkers are coming Melisandre tells John
Snow that she has seen pache face
in her visions and the flames and she
considers him to be a very dangerous man
Melisandre may have even seen him and to
see what the army of the Dead but there
is something else that happens right
around the same time that leads me to
believe the army of the Dead will go
into the sea
the Lord Commander of
eastwatch-by-the-sea is named Kotter
Pike and he is one of the people that
goes to hardhome to save the wildlings
in the books Jon Snow doesn't actually
go to hardhome but caught her Pike does
go
Johnson's caught her Pike to hardhome
because he doesn't want the wildlings
that are there to get turned into whites
just like in the TV show but when caught
her Pike arrives at hardhome
he sends a report back to Jon Snow and
he says there are dead things in the
woods and dead things in the water
caught her pike wasn't heard from ever
again after this and I think he saw the
others in the water when I start to
think about all the evidence it really
does start to point toward the army of
the Dead coming around the wall on the
frozen sea and that's how they will get
south of the wall there is one more
thing I want to show you before I go if
you know anything about george RR martin
then you should know George likes to
take things from real world history and
implement them into his story just like
the war between the Starks and the
Lannisters was loosely based off the War
of the Roses well something happened
during World War two that might have
been considered when it comes to how the
army of the Dead is going to get South
France spent 11 years in 450 million
dollars fortifying 450 miles of
countryside against the German
militarization they built this 450 mile
long wall to keep the Nazis out but when
the Nazis invaded in May of 1940 they
simply went around the wall and in this
case the others maybe the Nazis and they
will do the same instead of coming
through the wall or over the wall why
not take the easiest route and just go
around the damn thing without even
breaking a sweat but comment down below
and let me know what you think is there
something here or am I just crazy thanks
for stopping by and checking out this
video I really appreciate that and I
will see you all in my season 7 episode
2 breakdown video bye